- I've always said that, whatever I put
in my mouth is my business.
(laughter)
(easy music)
- Hello, my name is Scot Jones
and I am the Executive
Chef at Crossroads Kitchen
Los Angeles, California.
I started the plant-based restaurant with
Chrissy Hein in Akron, Ohio
called the Vegeteranian.
And that's when I got into
the plant-based cooking world.
Today they're trying
the Impossible Burger,
Chicken and Waffles,
the Crispy Chicken Milanese Sandwich,
and our Kale Caesar.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Oh I am so excited.
- This is so exciting.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Tastes like a burger, very good.
- It literally just
looks like ground beef.
- My love for cheeseburgers
is well documented
and I would eat these endlessly.
(upbeat music)
- It's a really good salad.
- It's really good.
- Kale, especially when
it's raw like this,
is hard to make taste good,
but this tastes really good.
- Yeah I would have no idea
there was no dairy in that dressing.
I could eat this every day
for the rest of my life I feel like.
(casual music)
(groaning)
(laughter)
- (inaudible) It just tastes
like a chicken sandwich.
Like my family's from Argentina,
we make Milanesas, it tastes like that.
- It reminds me of going to a deli
and just getting a nice
fresh sandwich from there.
- As someone who loves
chicken even specifically,
like I eat tons of chicken.
This is delicious.
(upbeat music)
- Mm
- Right?
- Mm. Mm.
- I would gladly eat this
every day of my life.
Question, so what's
different about the waffle?
- [Chef] Applesauce
- [Together] What?
- That sounds better anyway.
So you can just straight up
use applesauce instead of eggs
and why doesn't everyone do that?
- It's so much more fluffier too.
- Oh my god what's that over there?
(laughter)
So crazy how that worked out.
- Oh my god.
You killed that.
- Oh I can keep going.
More waffles please.
Waffle me.
- Chop chop.
- I just feel like you
could describe Crossroads as
good food with compassion.
- I'm just gonna say it I'm sorry,
I would eat this over
Rosco's chicken and waffles
in a heartbeat.
- I feel like when people say
oh I'm a vegetarian or vegan or whatever,
you think they just eat rice
and beans all day, or bananas.
Look at all this.
It could be more.
(casual music)
(hinges squeaking)